listen I just saw the post that said uh
there's a lot of pressure being in a
Will Ferrell holiday Christmas movie so
I want to know each of you how are you
feeling now that it is going to be out
and you're in a holiday movie with Will
I mean it's too late now
pressure's on him I don't know I mean he
set the bar I just have to limbo under
it so yeah I don't know terrifying
Octavia what does it feel like to be in
a holiday movie with Will
well it's uh all of those happy joyous
feelings and and then there's oh my God
I'm gonna
[Laughter]
let's just say dreams can come true and
they did
and when will they come true
Spencer would do it pretty good yeah
absolutely
look at the gate you're dissing and
you're
for this movie Ryan will start with you
tell us about them rehearsals were uh I
don't think I've ever done rehearsal
sessions that were this far in advance
so months months and months in advance
and then together we had a couple of
months as well in Boston where we were
sort of band camp so to speak and we're
singing and dancing every day and and um
it was incredible I remember I was
wearing like a one of the smart watches
to tell you the steps and most days it
was like 26 27 000 steps it was
completely crazy I looked like a slim
jim commercial yeah
the end of the movie it was wild you get
this false sense of confidence because
you work on the dance
you know by itself
then you work on the song by itself and
you never think oh wait I gotta combine
them at one point yeah and be on the
right foot on the right lyric and yeah
yeah we we I mean if anything we we've
come out of this with so much respect
for people who do musicals you know
every night eight shows a week yeah that
sort of thing absolutely except Hugh
Jackman he's been talking about exactly
and I like I'm I'm in with Ryan on the
Hue thing yeah thank God yeah well I was
going to ask you is is huge threatened
or or how does he feel about all of this
is he is I think he's threatened every
day he wakes up yeah yeah I sent him a
clip of me singing and dancing and and
to see if he was threatening and he he
responded just no I just said no he's
reaching out to me personally which is
desperate
desperate and I got some texts yeah yeah
you did yeah
in deadpool with Wolverine maybe you
could do like a dance thing together I
think it's what the fans want
to do that yeah I do that I love that
Octavia let's talk about your singing
you were so fantastic my question is
when you finish filming this this movie
did you walk around and like sing it
everyone instead of talk be like I would
like a coffee could you load the
dishwasher like did that is that what
happened after all this I was doing that
before so I had this uh inflated
confidence about singing and then I
realized wait a minute I sing in the
shower I sing when I'm getting my coffee
but that's not singing in a musical and
I learned very quickly uh that that is
not singing in a musical but we had the
best uh Voice coaches and uh trainers I
I mean I feel like you guys as producers
they did everything right to make sure
that we all felt confident by the end of
it now I'm not the best ice skater still
um but I can still sing in the shower
now yeah sort of like I always think of
it like uh running a marathon or
something about six billion years ago I
ran a marathon and I remember that
afterwards they're like people like oh
you're gonna do more you can do more of
this I was like no never like this is
the last time I jogged even because in
2008 uh so yeah now it's just and when
we're in the car even with the kids
there's no more baby shark it's just NPR
news
either of you
your character was everything we needed
in a ghost so I have to ask you if you
could haunt any other celebrity other
than Ryan this holiday season who would
it be
gonna fall backwards into my chair oh my
goodness
tough act to follow
if I say
just give them
oh yeah I don't know it was just
something what if you're just like Tim
Allen
it's just super random yeah yeah I mean
you can think about it for a bit and
then when it comes to you just yell it
out just like yell it I think Tim Allen
I would say Diane Keaton because I want
to just see what her kitchen looks like
but she has an amazing kitchen
Tim Allen okay perfect
I don't know why no thank you on set
Ryan was also helping me like he would
feed me some some like improvised I am
an internet certified life coach and it
was amazing I loved it
perfect
will whenever we think of holiday movies
your name comes up I mean we think of
you for a lot of reasons right you're
hilarious you're talented you're limber
all of it but when it comes to holiday
movies you're it right right no very
well that yes but uh what does it feel
like to be such a big part of people's
traditions and now you're out with
another movie that will be just as
spectacular what does that feel like
it um well we all know how tenuous and
you know tough this business is uh and I
don't
it's just it never stops being surreal
uh I mean it's wonderful it's incredible
but you know I always tell the story of
you know early days shooting that movie
running around New York City and my
yellow tights
thinking
this could be it
this could be the one where they went
whatever happened to that guy yeah
and so to have it you know
grow each year and year as kind of this
holiday classic is just it's it's
wonderful yeah we
oh and she told me what you wanted for
Christmas and she said she wanted you to
buy her a hockey team called the Ottawa
Senators so my question is
will that happen
you know just learning this oh yeah
um yeah I can't imagine Blake would make
that call
um yeah I think she'd go you know
directly to the mayor of Ottawa yeah
weirdly enough I uh at least with hockey
I know the rules whereas in and I've
owned a Welsh uh soccer team we call it
football but I'll say soccer for this
it's for for over two years now and I
would say that I'm a B minus at best on
the rules
so yeah let's see you didn't give me an
answer I know do you see I've been
watching political ads lately and I
thought that was just auditioning how to
how to do that yeah so depending on what
the definition of is is
uh so you're saying it's a maybe you're
saying it's a maybe I
I I'm not saying anything I'm not saying
anything unless it has to do with
Christmas yes yeah okay SUNY and Octavia
we're in on it we already have a
competing bid it's a Consortium right
here that is outside of we are
Consortium Consortium
Consortium I don't know yeah we're
looking to buy the Ottawa Senators for
one thousand dollars
well we would be happy to have you right
here
we're not playing around 1
000 I love this for us well I love you
all and we're so grateful for this movie
it is hilarious my whole family laughed
and we cried and smiled the whole way
through so thank you so much for this
gift it's wonderful and good afternoon
good afternoon good afternoon